[Music]
screw science yeah everything's up
survival survival survival at this point
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by mark rober he's
the nasa engineer turned youtube
juggernaut whose videos range from
carnival science exposes to building the
world's largest super soaker to the
annual porch pirate glitter bomb holiday
extravaganza he also has a new project
on the way called mark roberts
revengineers a hidden camera science
focused prank show coming soon to
discovery channel mark robert welcome to
the show i hate you
why am i here it's starting already how
are you around spicy food and do you
think that there's anything about your
science background that may give you an
edge as you take on the hot ones
challenge today
i know people sandbag and say they don't
do spicy stuff on the show like i legit
like taco bell mild sauce is like
pushing it for me like i won't do the
full packet so like i am at an extreme
disadvantage in that sense as a man of
science you know and as a firm believer
in the scientific method i will say that
i have i brought i brought some gifts
and i think we're going to try them as
we go along
and god willing they are going to help
me through this but uh but we'll see
[Music]
i'm gonna get started okay cool i'm
going on the offensive right here here
we go
cheers cheers
okay
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
now i'm ready
okay
now you
are kind of my control here right like
in science there's a control you've done
this what like 250 freaking times yeah
but who's counting i am you're crazy
okay so this is the classic garlic
fresno
[Music]
[Music]
oh wait maybe i can do this this isn't
that bad
as we mentioned in your intro you're
coming soon to discovery channel with
your show revenge aneers a hidden camera
prank show that uses science and
engineering to give bad samaritans their
comeuppance and your style of prank like
the wallet drop for example kind of
shows the duality of human nature does
playing out these thought exercises at
such scale does it make you more
optimistic or less optimistic about
society as a whole
um
that's a good question i think
honestly i feel like it's like more
optimistic i feel like people are
surprised that people are more honest
than they normally are now porch pirate
package people stealing that it's like
of course i'm not gonna air the person
who walks by and doesn't steal the
package right of course if you open it
then we reward you with like a pound of
freaking glitter and an uncharitable
amount of fart spray
so here's the first thing i do want to
try okay i've just got some petroleum
jelly what i want to do is
put this on like just your bottom lip
okay i don't know it like creates a
barrier again there's like control don't
do it on your upper lip
and let's see we can feel the difference
as things go along you know what i mean
okay
here we go
[Music]
there it is there it is a little bit a
little bit i was just about to say
something arrogant again and then it's
like
came with a little okay
that's all right
i'm feeling it a little bit more right
but like already we're
way past the point where i would like
order this at a restaurant
like i would be like that's too hot i'm
not gonna order that ever again
so before youtube you spent seven years
at nasa working on a car-sized rover
called curiosity which actually
successfully landed on mars in august
2012. can you explain to a dummy like me
the sort of key breakthroughs or things
that are learned through rovers like
curiosity or perseverance over the last
decade
yeah i mean essentially these rovers
that we're sending there are like scouts
for humanity like in the very near
future we'll be we will be a
multi-planetary species the first person
to step foot on mars is alive right now
it could be you watching this video you
could be the first person to step foot
on mars and i just love that thought but
before you go to mars
humans are going to live there we need
to know about mars so part of what
they're doing is going to mars to learn
about the history and is there water on
mars turns out there is
they're finding out what the solar
radiation is you know what the wind
levels are and the temperature
fluctuations they're gathering
information so that we could someday
send humans there
one of the coolest moments of my life
like the coolest picture potentially
i've ever seen just that first really
grainy image coming back from the rover
from a has cam black and white like
300 pixels by 300 pixels but it just
showed like the shadow of the rover on
the surface
and so you know she's in one piece and
just we just went nuts the whole place
erupted because it's freaking seven
years of your life of blood sweat toil
long hours
and to see it like there and it landed
and now being excited for the science of
return is just like an incredible
feeling especially because it could have
been a fiery mess could have been a
fiery mess
you saw the segway
he saw the segway coming speaking of
fiery messes uh let's pull out another
anecdote okay
this is just good old peanut butter and
i'll give you a spoon the idea here
is it's a lipid
you should kind of coat your mouth a
little bit
beforehand
to not allow that capsaicin to like get
on those one receptors let it coat it
i am coated okay
[Music]
all right
here we go
[Music]
this is another level
[Music]
yeah i can say it's it's up a little bit
yeah again would never order this from a
restaurant
can we get an update on the squirrels in
your backyard like how's fat gus living
these days
fat gus is living the life right now
because i'm filming 3.0 oh it's going to
be the olympics so they're all competing
and at this point they know the drill
you know because i'll film for about
four months with them and then i don't
really feed them the rest of the year
because i don't want them to come
depending on me so at the beginning of
filming when walnuts start coming out
again they're just like yes and like the
squirrels come from everywhere to the
chagrin of my neighbors very likely but
uh yeah fat gus is doing well thank you
for asking i'll let him know you asked
i'm excited about this one okay this
scientist this looks new to me this is
um throat numbing spray like if you have
a sore throat right
but i mean if this worked the reason i'm
introducing this early is we've got what
like uh
seven more to go right so maybe you can
get a couple wings out of this yeah yeah
yeah you better believe i'm gonna be
hitting this pretty strong up we're
going from a spray to a swig
all right here we go
[Music]
just keep it on the right side
okay all right i counted about seven
sprays in there yeah yeah
[Music]
oh takes you back to that like kid
medicine
okay you ready so this is the los
calientes verde here we go
[Music]
as a science buff is there a movie that
you have to tip your cap to hollywood
and the way that it depicts physics or
mechanical engineering i would say uh
and this may be a common answer among uh
engineers especially working at jpl the
martian and andy weir what he did and
the research he did like i loved that he
showed it can be done actually i mean
the end got a little weird i remember
he's like using his glove to like propel
himself around in space but like up to
that point like he the man did his
research having worked at jbl like built
rovers like and usually that's the
litmus test right if the people who are
really in the weeds if they're like yeah
but but i'm like dude props i learned
stuff for reading that book right so
that's i think i feel like that's the
gold standard
so on this one we're gonna try just a
sugar cube let's do two two just you
know
for good measure for good measure here
you go there's one good catch
okay here we go there you go okay
[Music]
i mean as the control we're doing all
right we're doing very good so far doing
good so far
i feel like
yeah obnoxiously overconfident at this
point
famous last words here we go
that's a big bite i deserve respect for
that right internet
[Music]
what have i done
taste it with the cube
okay
now that one sneaks up a little on you
mm-hmm
but thankfully we got the cubes we got
the cubes and while that cube melts in
your mouth mark robert we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we do a deep dive on
our guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull the picture up over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story
how big a thrill was it for you to meet
nitro and get ball rifled by the legend
himself amazing and he was like talking
trash against me too like you're going
down it's like oh this is amazing
uh the legend grew up watching that show
and for him to come out and i we made
his tennis ball cannon from the show but
like souped it way up in this new like
willy wonka warehouse i built and uh to
to try and avoid it and be like the
average drove from american gladiators
absolute dream come true how did it feel
when you got rifled because you're
terrible about like this
[Laughter]
all right one more for you
what's a behind the scenes nugget i can
sink my teeth into when it comes to
field goal kicking robot one of my
favorite videos on your entire channel
so yeah we built this robot that can
kick field goals like 110 yard field
goals uh and i went up against matt
prater who at the time
held the record for the world's longest
field goal kick what i'll say about matt
prater and field goal kickers in general
this day they don't necessarily kick
farther than field goal kickers maybe
like 20 30 years ago but they're so much
more consistent you can just tell on an
eyeball test watching football now yeah
they're just way way more consistent and
that's what matters for coaches so
literally when we were there he probably
kicked something like 40 field goals
like none of them not only they didn't
miss but like if these are the uprights
it was like middle 20
every time like that guy is so automatic
like the only time he missed is when we
finally got far enough back for my robot
trying to bomb it from 70 yards that's
right and that's where you know the
robot dominated of course but
i think it's time for the sour cream
again that's a pre-coat
we're just gonna go straight from the
container here
bang bang that's how we do it here on
hot ones
a little sour cream for science
[Music]
all right
here we go
[Music]
oh there it is yeah there it is i was
waiting for it
yeah it sneaks in but i saw in your eyes
almost an excitement to discover it you
know i didn't see a fear i didn't see a
fear in your eyes no no no it's
excitement that's one of my favorite
scientific quotes is
uh somewhere something amazing is
waiting to be discovered
like that's the excitement of science
it's like the unknown in answering these
questions like i love that just in my
everyday life
i will say that so far there is a
noticeable
change in the way that the experience is
hitting me interesting so normally by
this point you're just feeling it a
little bit more your brain is more like
yo you're on fire blow towards the mouth
and then it makes me wonder though
because this is the other thing i guess
you have to think about is like maybe
two how much of that is like
psychological you know like how much how
much of a going how much of what's going
on right now is like placebo total
placebo you know what i'm totally cool
with that i'll take like the placebo
effect is a real thing and i'm in it and
you know what else i've noticed is at
this point in the show
typically if there's someone who's is
inexperienced with hot sauce as you
milk is halfway gone i think because
we've been messing around with these
other things it's kind of made that like
completely unnecessary so far which i
think is another sign another piece of
evidence i think you're right yeah i
deserve some credit yeah i haven't even
touched the milk internet look at that
now we're getting into the cooler uh-oh
that's where you know it gets real
i know when gordon ramsay come on he did
try like the citrus and that is true
that will combat so the the capsaicin is
like a base so the citrus is kind of on
the opposite end of the ph scale it kind
of breaks it down so i took that one
step farther so these are like
just pure lemon ice cubes oh okay so you
get the cooling effect along with the
citrus effect
and uh we'll just plant those right
there i'll uh i'll i'll pass them over
to you once you take a bite okay so this
one is turfing's curse here in the seven
spot
oh i took a big bite there
oh wow
this one's not weight
just banging down the front door right
low car and this i will say
this is where it gets real very real
awesome
okay
wow
oh
whoa
whoa
how do you breathe should i breathe
through my nose or mouth hold on
and then like the sour ice cube
[Music]
it's kind of kicking off some like
teary-eyed physiological effects of its
own
well this is true
[Laughter]
it helps certainly when it's in yeah wow
by the way is it
is it
is it better to chew
and uh
screw science yeah everything's about
survival survival survival at this point
is it better to chew
and then swallow this is you know i
haven't i haven't i haven't read a book
i'm not like you mark i don't read books
but uh i think that like having big
chunks of spicy food i feel like that's
the that's the cramp starter i like to
break it all down
that was a significant knee in the curve
[Laughter]
i always see people like trying to touch
their eyes i'm like what morons why you
touch your eyes but now you understand i
want to touch my eyes so bad
[Laughter]
so earlier this year you launched the
crunch labs build box which gives kids
the opportunity to build the toys step
by step using engineering principles and
i've heard you make the point that cheap
toys have the most clever designs by
necessity what's a classic children's
toy that you recognize for its stem
ingenuity that the rest of us might take
for granted
great
question how dare you make me think
under these conditions
um
do you know what makes a frisbee fly no
but i'm on the edge of my seat this is
great this is amazing so
basically there's two things one is the
angle of attack which you know when it
flies it flies a little bit like this so
it's bumping into stationary air
molecules and basically deflecting up
it's like conservation momentum right
it's a reaction same thing when you put
your arm out the window it goes up and
down right you're bumping into air which
is a fluid and it's causing it to go up
or down that's the first thing the
second one which is really fascinating
is this thing called the koanda effect
you've ever taken a spoon and put it
under like running water
and when you put a curved spoon on water
it curves around right all fluids do
that the air is a fluid
so as this frisbee flies through the air
you notice it's curved right
basically as it passes over the air
all the air then turns and follows the
curvature down
and basically what's happening is it's
throwing air all around it down as it
flies like a jet pack
so like as a frisbee goes through the
air just like if you're wearing a jet
pack how it's like you're pushing air
down which again equips the action makes
you go up a frisbee is freaking jet
packing itself through the air as it
flies by and that's what makes it fly
and coast so well which is amazing if
you took the same frisbee and you had
sharp edges wouldn't fly nearly as well
um
have passed me to pass me the throat
spray here you go
yeah i gotcha i'm going full mouth there
we go
[Music]
we're ready
and on this this is ice cream i think
it's a better form of milk
okay
here we go
[Music]
it's really not that bad
i thought that was gonna be way worse
you're giving me that weight for it look
i'm not sure
[Music]
oh there it is there it is
that's how i was giving you that look
i texted jimmy on my way over jimmy
kimmel
he said you got to eat the whole thing
for science for science and i said oh
wow that comes in strong yeah
here let me give you your ice cream yeah
give me that back
i'm gonna take a little bit i'm gonna
clean the bone on this side there you go
for science we're lying
clean the bone baby
give me that dang ice cream yeah
you've earned it you've earned it and
you know what
it's amazing that you busted out the ice
cream
for this win can you extol the virtues
of eating ice cream with a fork and do
you still do that for efficiency a
hundred percent if i would have gotten
the the utensils here it would have been
a fork
good knowledge by the way
the
when your ice cream is like really hard
especially if you're using a fork
it contacts like there's a smaller
amount of surface area bro don't ask me
explain science
why have you give me the bomb
until it gets runny you don't really
need like a spoon
so i use a fork
it comes with the clorox ending there
you go yeah this is actually
i think of all the things this is the
most effective
excuse me this is the most
i mean i've never eaten anything to
spicy i never will again
[Music]
this is the whole milk ice cubes
[Music]
pick up some of those i'm in
oh these are funky
not the best taste no but
any portness storm
so you've been very busy this year
building out a headquarters launching
shows and then saving the ocean one
pound of trash at a time through your
collaborative fundraising effort with mr
beast team seas what was the most
eye-opening thing that you learned about
water pollution spending time in the
dominican republic aboard a ship that
eats trash
the most interesting thing to me there
was like
you see just these these
mountains of trash coming down the
rivers right and you're just like
there's a tire
there's a kid's toy there's a mattress
and you're like
what kind of jerk would just pollute a
river like this like that just seems so
obviously like not a good thing and so
then we took a trip up the river
to some of these really poor
neighborhoods
and the thing is it's like by no fault
of their own they just don't have a
place to put this trash they are like
living on landfills right
so the dominican republic you know the
government there totally recognizes
they're working on systemic solutions to
this problem in the meantime you know
boy on slat and you know the ocean
cleanup they've built this trash-eating
robot as kind of a band-aid fix it's not
supposed to be a permanent fix and
that's kind of what they say and what we
were saying with team c's is like this
is just a temporary thing
until the big problems get solved
systemically this is a stop gap measure
and there's nothing they want more that
we want more is for them to go out of
business you know you don't need this
charitable element to suck up this trash
as it comes down because you're solving
it upstream
it's just so exciting to see people use
clever engineering to solve real-world
problems and to know that i feel like
more and more kids are getting into stem
which i think is a good thing for the
world
all right mark robert
here we go i'm i'm going for it i do
feel like because i've been sciencing my
way out of this stuff i'm going hard on
this last dab
meat off the bone jimmy you're watching
we're dabbing we're dabbing we're gonna
match my dad i'm matching that's exactly
what i'm doing
how big of a mistake is this huh big
mistake you want to recant your thing
about not having plane issues i
well it's your problem
i'm going back to the hotel after this
fair enough here we go i'm going to the
pool
okay
whoa
i have a clean bone oh my god
i'm finishing strong
i'm very strong
what a sight to behold
yep
[Music]
i'm gonna wait as long as i can before i
go to the throat spray
that's all right because this question
it has a nice long wind up a nice long
wind up we're closing things out here
and i have to say that it was such a
treat to binge your channel and i love
just seeing the different ways that you
trick us into really caring about
science using your velociraptor hunting
method and as much as i love the
greatest hits like the glitter bomb
and the jello pool i'll always when i'm
watching somebody else on youtube i'll
always be fond of the decade plus sort
of backwards hat hey what's up youtube
kind of era of a creator so with that in
mind i don't know if you remember this
but i have a quarter
amazing
and i'm wondering if you remember
the way to always flip a tails yeah i do
i stand up go ahead go ahead it's still
covered we got you mitch is on it
what you do is as you bring your arm up
you turn your thumb a little bit
you give it an off-axis rotation so it
spins like this right
i don't know if you can see that so what
happens is heads basically is like
continuously facing up
this works for me every time i have to
do a coin flip and i want to cheat my
way to win
so like that is heads
right
that is definitely heads so you can just
keep you could freaking flip 10 heads in
a row wow and i can see when you see
that hourglass shape in the air you know
it's going to be heads
and nobody notices this is why by the
way on big sporting events when they
flip it
they let it hit the ground because
otherwise you could grab it and sort of
and sort of get get the result you want
wow well speaking of results
here's what i have to say here at the
end yeah
during
the whole wing eating thing yeah i felt
like i was in a better place really
after and i don't know if it's the
cumulative effect i don't know what's
that monster dab
i feel awful ass
asked you i'm glad the control agrees
because that's how i feel
i will never do this again this is a
mistake i don't know why people eat hot
sauce
some questions science just can't answer
look at you
mark robert taking on the wings of death
and living to tell the tale now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you this camera this camera
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
i'm just on youtube at mark grover i got
the tv show of engineers i did on
discovery and we just launched the
crunch labs which is basically a box you
get every month and you make a build
alongside me and i teach you to think
like an engineer
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
what a gauntlet man
what a gauntlet
here comes the burps
hey what's going on hot ones fans we
brought the heat to the freezer aisle
with our hot ones boneless chicken bites
and used smash sales records and all of
our wildest expectations so what did we
do we made more that's right we are in
with five new flavors of hot ones
boneless chicken bites and five new ways
for you to bring hot ones home from the
classic to the classic garlic fresno
edition to the los calientes trio of
flavor verde rojo barbacoa visit hot
ones challenge dot com for more
information and to find a store near you
hot ones boneless chicken bites you're
in the hot seat now